[Müzik]
İyi akşamlar
[Alkış]
Benim işim zor çünkü hem diğer
konuşmacılar Ve eminim burada Bu salonda
bulunan herkesin mesleği
Şahane mesleklerdir bana sorduklarında
cazcıyım diyorlar
Herkes diyor ki caz yapma
değil mi Bizde böyle bir şey var cihaz
yapmam Benim işim bir gıdığımız zor
başınızı çok ağrıtmayacağım ama bu
teklif bu konu üstünde
konuşmak üzere Bana geldiğinde ben bunun
iki dilli geldiğini ayağa kalk ve
standap olduğunu gördüm ve ben İngilizce
sizden de batakıldım
hemen hatırladım standap Aslında 12
yüzyıl İngiltere'de
yumruk dövüşü yapan boksörlerin yere
yıkılana
bütün seyircilerin tezahüratla
bağırdıkları ayağa kalk standarttan mı
gelmekte
Oysa bugün stentab'ı Biz başka bir şey
biliyoruz değil mi Bir sürü çok komiksin
Keşke ben de onlardan biri olsaydım Ama
ben sizi biraz sıkacağım yani yapacak
bir şey yok
İngilizcede stand up bir başka manası 16
yüzyılda
kendi haklı davanı
savunmakla ilgili
stand up kendi hukuki davanın ya da
haklı olduğun her neyse o konuda
ayakta durmak
16 yüzyılda böyle bir hale gelmişsin
daha sonra böyle 1900'lerin başında
randevu
yaptığın kişiyi bekletmek
yani bizdeki ağaç oldum abi var ya onun
gibi bir şey istenen
öyle duruyorsun
daha sonra Muhtemelen
1950'lerin sonuna doğru bir yerlerde ya
da ikinci yarısında
CBS televizyonunda yayınlanan bir dizi
film
ilk defa stand up komedi başlıyor ve
1966 tarihinde bu onaylanıyor artık
stand up
çıkıp
cesurca
düşündüğünü anlatmak söylemek oluyor
Çünkü stentab'ın bir diğer manası da
gerçekten Cesur
İngilizce'de
sonra ayağa kalkmaya takıldım ayak
Türkçe'de adaktan geldiğini biliyorum
ayağa Adak denen bir sürü diyalek var
sonra o adaktan kendini adamaya geldim
herhangi bir davaya vesaire Herhangi bir
şeye kendinize adaya bilirsiniz
ya Umarım öyledir yani Türkçe senin tam
olarak nereden geldiğini bilmek zor ama
böyle düşünmek çok romantik hoşuma
gidiyor
cihazı
Evet bir Amerikan sanat biçimi diye
bütün ansiklopedilerde yazar
Tamam gerçekten öyle midir
gerçekten ilk siyahi köle Afrika'dan
Amerika kıtasına götürülmeseydi şimdi
bütün konuşmacılar dedi ya sizi
görmüyorum Evet görünmüyorsunuz şöyle
yaptığımda bile Evet belki biraz hani
yaş
grubunuzu bilemiyorum ama Kunta Kinte
kimler için bir şeyleri ifade ediyor
Bilmiyorum ama ünlü Roman kökler veya
onun dizi filmi TRT'de çok güzel
zamanlarda yayınlanmıştı oranın baş
kahramanı Kunta Kinte enseye tokat
Afrika'dan alıp Amerika'ya götürülen ilk
köleler ve oradaki
eziyet çile Her şey bir araya geldiğinde
yepyeni bir sanat formu doğuyor
gaz müziği
caz yapma
Bilmem Muhtemelen onlara da öyle
demişlerdir Çünkü
Amerika'nın ünlü iç savaşı kuzey ve
güneyliler birbirlerini öldürürlerken
cephede Tabii ki müzisyenler de var yani
bandımızı kabirliği
İşte onların cesetlerinin üstünden
siyahların ele geçirmiş olduğu bir takım
enstrümanları alarak
toplanıp Afrika geleneğini sürdürüp
aynı
grameri kullanarak
yarattıkları bir yeni müzik türü
fakat içinde son derece önemli bir şey
var
doğaçlama
doğaçlamak zorundasınız
Yani ben de bugün acaba ne konuşsam diye
düşündüm ama şu an bu açılıyorum Şu an
ne konuşacağımı bilmiyorum
ama hayat zaten böyle bir şey değil mi
doğaçlamak zorundasınız doğaçlamadığınız
bir an var mı Bence yok
doğaçlanmayan müzikler var mı
Tabii ki var çok büyük saygı ama gelin
gaz müziğinin
çok önemli bir dönemini örnek olarak
alalım ve gaz müziği yine nasıl tarihe
iz bırakarak devam ettiği ya da tarihin
gaz müziği üstünden okunabileceğinin
altını çizelim
kene diye
suikastiların ortaları
o sırada Amerika'dan Eğer oluyor yani
ister istemez ama Amerika'yı konuşmak
zorundayız caz deyince
o sırada Almanya'da caz yok orada var
Hatta hala o öyle olduğu düşünülüyor
Türkiye'de var mı çok emin değilim
Türkiye'de
biraz bu konular hep mış gibi
ama
zamanı geldiğinde o da olacak
kene diye suikast
o sırada malcomex diye bir adam var
Martin'in diye bir adam var
özgürlük diye sesleniyor her şey
özgürlük üstüne
konuşuluyor
Cesur var Muhammed Ali oluyor malkome
üstünden özgürlüğü savunuyor hatırlayın
o yılları biraz
işte bütün dünyada özgür olmak
konuşulurken
gaz kendi içinde hemen Özgür doğaçlamayı
barındıran İngilizcesi olan o
müthiş türünü
hayatın içinden alıp geliyor Yani
aslında gaz müziği yaşayan bir sanat
biçimi
Şu an ne yaşıyorsanız caz müziği
O şekle geliyor Su Gibi
suyu hangi kaba koyarsanız O şekle alır
caz müziği biraz öyle
bizim topraklara yabancı
yabancı
tam bunu kabul edecekken hemen Harvard
Üniversitesi'nde bir
doçentlik bezini
okuduğumu hatırlıyorum başlığı çok güzel
Türkler olmasaydı gaz müziği olmazdı
Ne alakası var
zevkle ve merakla okudum Tabii ki
Türklerin
Büyük Asya Göçünü
ele alıyor Eğer Türkler
kim tarafından Anadolu'ya Anadolu'dan
Avrupa'ya ve Avrupa'da etkileşimden
sonra Amerika kıtasına taşınmasaydı
davul ve zil olmayacaktı O Türklerin
göçüyle gelen ve o yüzden de Türklere
mal edilen iki tane enstrüman ve bugün
gaz müziğinin olmazsa olmazı
düştüğün zaman
kalkıyorsun ayağa kalkıyorsun
ayağa kalkmak Acaba gerçekten yalnızca
düştüğünüzde yaptığımız bir eylem mi
ben kuşkuluyum
uyumak
her gün düşmeyebilirsiniz ama her gün
uyumak zorundasınız
uyuduğunuzda da tekrar ayağa kalkmak
zorundasınız Ya çok uzun bir
uykudaysanız
Pamuk Prenses mi misali bizi öpecek bir
prenses de yok işte özür dilerim Prens
de yok
bizi kim öpecek ya da bizi kim öpüyor
öpeyim abi
Hayır Öpücem de öptüğünde hemen uyanacak
mıyım
O yüzden bana sorarsanız caz müziği ile
de çok bağdaştırdığım bu uyuma uyuşma
meselesi
Bence düşüp kalkmaktan daha önemli
bir an önce
uyanma dileğiyle huzurunuzdan
ayrılıyorum
[Alkış]